what's the deal with airplane
peanuts highly intense onair
confrontations have been happening since
the very beginning of broadcast radio
and the new era of Comedy podcasting is
no different from false accusations what
the is this to Joe Rogan roasting his
own guests you don't understand what
you're saying saying these are the top
five most intense moments in podcast
history starting off with the time that
Eddie Bravo went a little too deep into
Flat Earth it doesn't matter
flat around it doesn't matter fallback
you keep saying that it's a bad fallback
because what what we're saying is there
are conspiracies the problem is when you
think everything is conspiracy you act
as a scop guy and you [__] people over
that want to look at real
conspiracies the real conspiracy the G
of ton that's what I thought too like
the Gul of tonan real real like
operation Northwoods real things that
really happened when you look at those
things and people explore them they go
oh I don't think they really killed
Kennedy are you sure why don't you look
at this look at this stuff there's a lot
of really crazy evidence when you start
thinking that the world is flat the
Dinosaurs Aren't real all this nutty
[__] that you believe the problem is it
discredits all these other things that
you believe that might be real cuz the
other things have some validity to that
you just haven't looked into it that's
all Eddie I used to say the same Ed
you're talking about the Earth being
flat thousands of scientists have look
into it you think they're all wrong
that's so insane you haven't looked into
it I have no you have oh my God how
could I not have you don't think I have
I'm watching you go down the rabbit hole
you don't think I Tred to pay attention
to what the [__] these people are
talking about it doesn't work I don't
think so Eddie there's website's
dedicated to debunking it it's dedicated
to showing you the science showing you
the math that you can do how come when
you check the internet it's valid but
when I'm on the Internet it's not you're
not talking about the internet you're
talking about a Guys YouTube vide no
it's not a guys there's a lot of guys
there's a lot of people but they're just
YouTube videos the science behind them
is not verified by
journals the science of the Earth the
government science that's bought and
paid for of course you start talking
about
flatter one of these guys shows up again
on this list so be sure to stick around
until the end cuz at number four is the
time fresh and fit visited flagrant like
you guys that's why I don't understand
how you you don't see an issue with what
you said comedian I'm I always got I can
understand I'm trying to be funny and I
Mis some [__] but then when I peel it
back and I go to and I dig into what
you're saying it's still just it's more
troubling than me so say that like say
hey I misspoke I I told the bad joke but
you guys are doubling down and saying
you're like there's nothing wrong with
what I said nope there nothing wrong at
all but I don't but that's [__] y
both said that you date black women as
long as they fit the things you want
it's not a normal preference no no but
like like okay okay you're taking
doublin dark as like every blogger was
saying Laquisha Londa I'm not they know
Hood black chick bro hell no so so you
misspoke you made a bad joke [__] we
said it's a joke no but I'm saying so
you said so you made a bad joke so you
wish you didn't say that no like but
you're being Hypocrites you're being
hypocrit this is I don't know I I just
feel like it's ego like sometimes we get
in a situation where like I said some
[__] listen we do this [__] all the
[__] time right you say some [__] and
then you get all this backlash and
you're like man [__] all these people
I'm going stand on this [__] to the end
of time but if it's not really what you
feel then what you standing on like you
I think are being the most honest you I
think got too much
ego that there's a lot of reading into
this clip from like a year ago of us
just having a good time you're making
about the clip I'm making about what
you're saying right now my preference is
which is honestly [__] it is I don't
want to date black girls that's the way
every black dude that [__] white girls
says it I dated black girls in my life
all right bro who who the [__] hasn't
except me you know what I mean everybody
going to dabble in everything it is the
mentality that I have an issue with and
Alex is upset with the specific words
true but underneath it he's upset with
the mentality and the words bothered him
but I think the mentality would still be
Troublesome to him where it's like what
is I I I need a girl that's submissive
like that's if y'all are really trying
to help man that [__] is nice bro cuz I
I
one it's nice but it's a lot of [__]
that difficult bro no it's fine a lot of
stuff you guys say in general I think is
stuff that's kind of childish it is I
saw a clip where you were like oh the
nuclear family is falling apart what do
you do I don't get married just don't
get married you actually trying to help
man are you talking to [__] incels
who are 18 years old you know what I
mean that's some [__] you say to college
I'm going to turn you from a S to a pimp
all right bro can we grow up you guys
are self-help you are hey we're trying
to help men so either we're funny or
help men and be real and be honest with
yourselves and don't have an ego like I
just you know I have a preference be
honest have an honest conversation and I
don't think the Manis feere or manae or
whatever I don't think it's a bad thing
I think there are people who are doing
it really well the roommates H who you
that's who put me on to you guys great
let's just be mature about what we feel
and part of that maturity is yeah it was
a bad joke I don't actually feel exactly
that way I mean if you guys feel that
way that's fine but we make our content
you know what I'm saying people enjoy it
we we make jokes on it we provide
entertainment we provide education we do
everything because if you just only
provide you know self-help stuff without
any type of entertainment value people
AR going to
jokes I don't have a problem with the
joke telling you coming in at number
three is maybe the funniest moment on
this entire list the time Shane Gillis
triggered an entire room of comedians on
the you know what dude podcast when
talking about daddy daughter dances I
got a question do you at the daughter
Daddy dance you guys swap daughters and
grind with the other kids too no they
made that joke last time uh they did
yeah oh I'm here I'm out
here hang on one second hot in here by
Nelly please do you guys swap dolls can
you give this to him that's called the
bomb bandana that's not a bomb dude I'll
stand by that no no you can't we let you
know if it's a bomb it's like a crowd
you can't go you can't go on stage and L
right
now no you can't go on stage and then
you stink and then you go no it's not me
it's you no it's you you [__] that
was a bad one you took a hot one take a
hit what was bad about it I don't know
we didn't
laugh nobody laugh are friends you have
no idea that doesn't matter I laughed at
you [__] 10 times already all right
don't [__] this is the wrong with this
[__] [__] generation what are you
talking about take they can't take a hit
I've been smashed to shut the [__] up
I've been smashed on my podcast I take
most of the hits and I laugh if it's
funny one thing not funny this [__]
dip spitting [__] redneck deer clide
[__] no it's funny it's not you
stink you're over [__] rated already
shut the [__] up I hope you never work
in this [__] club
again welcome to the
show right I got to stop getting
triggered verie w I talked to my
therapist about this I'm ready to get
amped up about this dance and then that
just happened so you just took my
thunder away I think some of it I just
gave him was from the dance that wasn't
all qu you some of it was from this
[__]
[__] like what you're saying Bobby about
him or the dance no no about the
dance number two on this list comes to
us from taste buds when Joe D roza and
Sav Alano battling weed versus alcohol
led to what they'd later call their most
personal fight ever on the show but what
do you mean of course you how is that
not you are sometimes you get me so
upset you you contradict yourself from
saying contradicting myself which is it
Joe is 15 milligrams not a lot of weed
or is 50 migs enough to make you think
you're going to die way more dangerous
than you make it out to be I'm a college
kid I'm funneling [__] pump my stomach
in the hospital because
God no it's not the same talk about the
the most common experience with each
okay s I'm common experience a lot you
know how many people I know that say I
can't smoke weed it makes me crazy it
makes me paranoid I don't know anybody
that I no no I take that back I take
that back I'm not going to speak I'm not
going to speak in generalities I know a
lot of people that say I can't smoke
weed it makes me crazy it makes me
paranoid I know people who are heavy
mushroom and acid users that say weed is
the devil it is the devil I know people
nobody's losing their families over weed
nobody's losing their job over weed okay
nobody's losing their life over weed
[__] they are
not as much as
booze talk to all the girls go talk to
all the girls I know that say they had
to dump their boyfriends cuz all he did
was sit on the couch and hit his bong
and play video games all day nobody Los
anything over week okay go talk to all
the people that have broken homes
because the guy the people drink alcoh
let's go back to the general user
experience let's say you just asked me
to prove a point and I proved it and you
shot it down you proving [__] okay you
ain't proving
[__] okay let's go to the regular p in
the trash can is me having a panic
attack okay so let's go to the I'm keep
trying to go to the to the most basic
experience for each thing I smoke a half
a joint or a joint I chill out that
night okay nothing's happening to me
odds are if you're going to drink you're
either going to be able to stop or
you're not it's way more common for
someone who's indulging in just one
drink or two drinks that night to end up
getting drunk when they didn't want to
and end up having a shitty day the next
day there's way more common for the
average alcohol user to end up with a
bad experience from alcohol than it is
for the average weed smoker to end up
with a bad experience say this to that I
would say this I will 100% agree with
you that the immediate hangover of
alcohol is far more robust than the
immediate hangover or effects of weed
but I will not stand here and let you
say that continual and habitual weed use
does not have a long-term horrible
effect on a human being it does it it
makes people forgetful it makes holy
[__] Joe why are you going back to
continued and habitual we don't need to
argue we don't need to argue I thought I
was going to die I was so high and he's
going to pump my stomach let's go back
to the way that most people experience
these things that's what I'm talking
about most people I know that smoke weed
smoke it habitually they smoke it daily
stop take away the habitual just
people's you can't take you're not an
alcoholic or a pothead let's talk about
that that's what I'm talking about
that's what I'm talking about so do you
I I sometimes I feel like I'm going
crazy I feel like I'm going crazy you
think our friends do let's go back to
the most relatable form of this you
think our friends that smoke weed uh on
every night are potheads yes okay well
that's not how I would that's not how
earlier what is a pothead I would say
around the clock pot smokers I don't
think somebody that has a drink every
night is an alcoholic I don't think
somebody that hits weed every night is
is a pothead I think if you I mean
that's really the ter that's really
exactly the definition all right so you
drink every day you're an alcoholic you
smoke every day you're probably you have
two glasses of wine every day you're an
alcoholic actually textbook you probably
are although I get it consuming seven
come on guys what are we talking about
here seven drinks per week then then s
and I are both alcoholics so then so so
your opinion is better than the National
Institute on alcohol abuse and
alcoholism people that dedicated their
you think you're Al so you're an
alcoholic you agree with that you're an
alcoholic no I don't I don't have seven
or more drinks a week no [__] you
insane are you insane no I don't swear
to God Hand to God Hand to god stop Joe
Joe Joe you wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute wait wait a minute maybe
this is an intervention maybe this is an
intervention for you you believe that
every week I consistently have more than
seven drinks a week out of your at least
have seven G if there is a week where we
hang and I drink one night seven drinks
that's the one night I will I I'm
telling you to your face right now I
would say if you average my drink
consumption over the course of a year
and average I don't even there's weeks
that I don't drink weeks that I don't
even have a drink you you're insane
seven so you think I'm having you think
I'm having four at least two times in a
week I'm having four drinks a night
[__] you just said you have a drink
with dinner very often that's seven days
in a week if you have a glass of wine
every night with dinner that would I
don't have a Dr of wine every night with
dinner I have I enjoy having wine with
dinner usually if I'm out I just hate Jo
you just you just make [__] up make [__]
up you just but you now I hang out with
you every week oh my God Joe my goodness
I hang out with you every week right
right I hang out with you every week
yeah and when I hang out with you every
week every week if I if you see me at
the club do I what do I have if I go
there a drink I've seen you have drinks
right a drink right and then I go home
right and then let's say the next more
like two three let's say I do let's say
I do two nights of of stand up a week
maybe one night let's say I do three
that's average one night I don't drink
two nights I have one night I have two
one night I have one that's three you're
telling me I consistently have over
seven a week it I don't no seven at
least seven I didn't say over seven I
don't just cuz you have seven a day I
don't have seven a day okay well if I
was you right now and you said that I'd
be like what yes you do the way you
flipped out is insane I don't have over
seven drinks a week before we reveal the
most intense moment in podcast history
please be sure to subscribe because at
number one is the most famous
confrontation on this list when Brendan
sha went on tiger belly and accused
Bobby and Kila of being the mastermines
behind his Reddit hate it's a story
that's been talked about to death at
this point but it's still number one on
this list by far the line was what am I
going to do suck your unfunny dick and
then I I came back with as far as me
again I I didn't see it but as far as
she's saying I I asked her to walk in my
car or give her a a ride no I I think
that I you I cannot speak for her I can
I'm saying I can only tell you what was
said on that particular podcast and
again if that's how she feels she's
validated to feel like that and I'm tell
you that's that never happened okay
that's a situation you would have to
talk to her about but I'm going to get
back to the podcast itself the what was
said was that there was a guy he was
unfunny I came back with oh that's a big
clue something about a peach emoji and
then but my thing with that do you think
that's nice oh no but I didn't say your
name but it's it's hang on one second
Brendan let me tell let me ask you this
if we're having this discussion about
something that happened in the past and
we're having a giggly little girl talk
where is the crime in that there's no
crime you can do whatever you want right
I have no issue with that go ahead okay
yeah have no issue with it all right I'm
just saying is that is that nice that's
all I have gone to you and said if I
could go back if I had no known that a
tiny little giggly girl talk was going
to spiral into this I would have wired
my mouth shut but in my heart of hearts
while you may think it's not nice and
now I admit not the nicest thing to say
it was just an anecdote
sure at joke
world did it joke
world and the world is
wld that's a great uh YouTube channel
joke World check it out